I went through when I was 18 years old
and I was either going to go to Berkeley
School of Music or I was going to go to
CIA was kind of like this like big life
decision because I was you know I
studied music my my whole life primarily
guitar but other things too and you know
i got into both and i just made a
decision to go to CIA i think it was
kind of a kind of a very fiscal decision
because i knew a lot of musicians that
didn't live in nice apartments and
didn't drive you know nice cars and i
love to cook anyways it just seems the
business of food was a little bit more
secure than the business of guitar
playing at the time I remember
definitely making that decision I'm glad
I went to school when I did if
everything I know now Anna said I don't
know if I would have done that again I
would you know you can really get it
education by not going to school when I
was 18 and being from Cleveland like I
didn't know I could go to France I
didn't know that I could work at three
star Michelin restaurants I didn't know
that I could get tours of the greatest
why places I didn't know I could go to
Italy and work at shred three is you
know and I did all that and I didn't
even think about you know coming to New
York at the time but it kind of gave me
a little bit of Base to go be able to do
all these things so I'm glad I went when
I was 18 I don't know maybe if I was 24
that I would have gone and done that but
for me at that time it was a good thing
I think it's really the scope of what
the business could be I mean there's a
lot of people to go to CIA that are
don't cook anymore don't aren't even the
restaurant business or you don't mean
you know being a chef releasing on facet
of you know the whole especially now I
mean now there's you know there's you
know there's food stylists and private
chefs I spoke at graduation and CIA by
the year and a half ago and I was amazed
the amount of graduates I mean that were
there compared to 17 years ago when I
graduated but also you know what they
were telling me I said oh well you know
what you're doing after graduation and
no one cuz I'm of the school like you
know my kind of group of friends was all
about coming to New York and working for
the great chefs and they were like maybe
five or six at that time no one was
coming to New York some were going to be
food stylists recipe testers some were
going straight to food TV some were
getting out of school and becoming
consultants without really having a lot
of real-world experience there was
private chef people there were you know
people that wanted to go straight to
hotels it was just a lot of different
you know a lot of other sub kind of
genres for for working in the business
besides being like chef guy
I mean your finances it depends on who
your teacher is really I the way I you
know deal with cooks now I think it's
kind of a mix a little bit of you know
true mentoring and letting them figure
things out for themselves i mean i think
the oppressive process the old
apprenticeship process in europe it
mates for a little bit close mindedness
a little bit and a little bit less room
for growth because you know this way and
that's the only way you know what I do
like about it and it's really missing
from the culture of like i would say
modern kitchens a little bit is what the
French would call you know men ta or
craftsmanship or you know dedication to
one's craft but also the way you behave
in restaurants of the way you deal with
dedication and so I think it's you know
some things are good about their system
and some things now in two thousand
eight ER and antiquity